Trump has obviously had a major boost in
the polls as a result of of this farce
Ron DeSantis is sort of a diminished
figure would you not say or slightly
knocked out the picture now and a lot of
people speculate that that's exactly
what the Democrats want and maybe this
is what it's all about it's an attempt
to make Donald Trump the nominee because
the Democrats think rightly or wrongly
that they can beat him careful what you
wish for they tried that once before and
he won in 2016. I mean we've seen this
movie before earned media coverage where
the media goes wall to wall Trump and no
one else can gain any Oxygen the
candidate himself you think he's going
to be under attack and seen as
disgusting and somebody nobody would
want anything to do with where in fact
the American people see him as
persecuted and the victim of an
overreaching left and are impressed by
his fortitude and his strength and his
unwillingness to back down